Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Lorsqu'on surfe sur internet
avec un ordinateur ou un smartphone,
on laisse inévitablement des traces
de notre passage :
notre adresse numérique,
notre adresse IP ou encore ces fameux
cookies qu'on nous demande d'accepter ou de refuser quand on consulte un site.
Toutes ces informations permettent de nous pister.
La plupart du temps pour nous proposer
de la publicité pour des produits
qui sont censés nous intéresser.
Pour éviter ce désagrément,
certains ont trouvé la parade,
ils utilisent la navigation privée.
Mais est-ce vraiment efficace ?
Peut-on naviguer sur Internet
sans être traqué ?
Aujourd'hui, Michael, de la chaîne Micode, vient nous éclairer, en mode incognito.
Bonjour Jamy !
Pour le savoir,
je vais d'abord vous expliquer
quelles sont les réelles différences
entre le mode classique
et la navigation privée,
aussi appelée mode incognito.
Il y a 4 différences.
La navigation privée ne conserve pas
votre historique de navigation.
Si vous cherchez à faire un cadeau à une
personne qui partage votre ordinateur,
c'est pour le coup très utile.
Les données saisies dans les formulaires,
que ce soit votre numéro client
ou votre adresse
mail de connexion à Facebook,
ne seront pas retenues
par votre navigateur.
C'est pratique
si vous surfez sur un ordinateur
qui ne vous appartient pas.
Troisièmement, les extensions que vous utilisez sont désactivées par défaut.
Et enfin, les fameux cookies ne sont pas
non plus stockés par votre navigateur.
Voilà, c'est tout.
Comment je le sais ?
C'est écrit noir sur blanc
à l'ouverture de la fenêtre.
Ou plutôt blanc sur noir.
Si j'ai bien compris,
si les cookies sont bloqués,
vous êtes tranquilles,
vous pouvez surfer incognito.
Non, pas vraiment, Jamy.
Déjà, les cookies ne sont pas
les plus méchants de l'histoire.
Un cookie, c'est un fichier texte,
plus exactement, une variable avec un nom et une valeur associée
et s'ils existent, c'est pour une bonne raison.
Il permet de stocker
des petites informations
utilisées par quasiment
tous les sites web.
La langue que nous utilisons,
ce que nous avons mis dans notre panier
de tel ou tel site d'e-commerce, ou encore
nos identifiants pour nous connecter
à notre boîte mail ou n'importe
quel autre service en ligne.
La fameuse case “se souvenir de moi”.
Et croyez-moi, au bout de
la troisième connexion à vos mails
en une journée de navigation privée,
vous en aurez déjà
marre de devoir saisir vos identifiants,
à chaque fois.
Bref, vous l'aurez compris,
un cookie c'est utile.
Jusqu'au jour où les publicitaires y ont vu une opportunité en or
de mieux nous connaître.
Les fameux cookies tiers,
ce sont les fameuses bannières :
“Accepter tous les cookies”.
Ça, je connais.
A l'origine,
les cookies sont déposés par le site web
que nous sommes en train de consulter,
ça paraît plutôt logique.
Mais les cookies tiers, eux, sont,
comme leur nom l'indique,
déposés par des tiers.
Il s'agit, par exemple,
de régies publicitaires très puissantes
comme Google ou Facebook.
Ces cookies leur permettent de connaître
quelles pages nous avons visités,
de déterminer nos habitudes sur Internet
et de constituer un profil complexe
de notre personnalité, afin de nous
afficher de la publicité très ciblée.
En développant
des outils très pratiques et gratuits
pour les développeurs de sites web,
ces régies font en sorte
d'être présentes partout sur le Web.
Ainsi, grâce aux cookies tiers
déposés à l'aide de ces outils,
ils sont en capacité de nous suivre
quasiment à la trace sur internet
et de toujours mieux
connaître nos habitudes.
Tenez, par exemple,
si je fais une recherche pour m'acheter une nouvelle machine à café
sur un site spécialisé, et bien, je serai
automatiquement ciblé sur tous les sites
que je consulterai les jours suivants
par des publicités de machine à café.
Ça m'arrive tout le temps,
j'en ai marre, si j'ose dire.
Oui, Jamy, c'est un peu pénible
et ça porte un nom : le "retargeting".
On s'est amusé à faire le test
avec le profil
d'un membre de l'équipe, sur Facebook.
C'est impressionnant
tout ce que ce réseau social a collecté
d'informations sur ses centres d'intérêt.
Et, c'est exactement la même chose avec Google.
Du coup, Michael, la navigation privée est-elle suffisante
pour se protéger de ce pistage ?
Eh non, les cookies tiers sont extrêmement efficaces pour nous suivre.
En navigation privée,
à la fermeture de notre fenêtre,
ces cookies sont détruits.
On pourrait se dire "c'est tout bon",
malheureusement, à eux seuls,
les cookies tiers ne constituent pas
l'unique moyen de nous pister.
Premièrement, Jamy,
si tu te connectes en navigation privée
avec ton compte Google ou Facebook,
quand bien même les cookies tiers
ne peuvent te suivre,
tu leur donne explicitement l'information :
“C'est moi, Jamy, qui vient de me connecter
et j'ai absolument besoin
d'une nouvelle machine à café.”
Tous les efforts sont réduits à néant.
Deuxièmement, en navigation privée,
notre adresse IP est toujours visible.
C'est elle qui permet de nous identifier
à travers internet
et navigation privée ou pas,
elle est absolument nécessaire
pour nous afficher le site web
qu'on a demandé.
L'adresse IP est une donnée personnelle,
par excellence.
Elle permet de nous identifier.
C'est grâce à elle,
par exemple, que l'ancienne
loi Hadopi remontait jusqu'à
nous, lors d'un téléchargement illégal.
Enfin, une dernière méthode existe
pour nous pister sans l'aide des cookies tiers ni de notre adresse IP :
"le fingerprinting",
nos empreintes digitales
et c'est absolument redoutable.
Mes empreintes digitales ?
Comment font les sites pour mettre la main sur mes empreintes digitales ?
Non Jamy, je ne parle pas de tes empreintes à toi,
mais de celles de ton navigateur.
Je vous explique, pour qu'un site web s'affiche correctement,
il a besoin de connaitre tout
un tas de détails techniques
à propos de votre navigateur : sa largeur,
la langue utilisée,
la résolution de notre écran,
la présence d'extensions,
la liste des polices installées,
j'en passe...
Mais mises bout à bout, toutes ces
spécificités, anodines au premier abord,
constituent l'empreinte quasiment unique
de mon navigateur ou du tiens, Jamy,
d'où le parallèle
avec les empreintes digitales.
Une enquête de l’EFF, l'Electronic Frontier Foundation,
une ONG respectée dans le milieu du numérique, a montré que 83,6%
de nos navigateurs
utilisent une empreinte unique.
Votre navigateur, ou plutôt son empreinte,
a de très grandes chances d'être unique.
Cette empreinte existe également
sur nos téléphones
et les développeurs d'applications
l'ont d'ailleurs très bien compris.
En 2021, quand Apple a imposé son "App Tracking Transparency",
vous savez, cette petite pop-up
qui demande aux utilisateurs
d'IPhone à l'ouverture d'une application,
s'ils souhaitent être suivis.
Et bien, les applications basées sur la pub
ont vu leurs revenus s'effondrer.
Pour y faire face
et contourner cette mesure,
certains développeurs
ont donc pris le parti d'utiliser
le fingerprinting de votre téléphone
afin de vous identifier, malgré tout.
Du coup, Michael,
la navigation privée,
ça ne sert pas à grand chose ?
Mais si Jamy, elle est toujours utile,
mais uniquement dans un cas bien précis.
Si vous utilisez une machine partagée,
un ordinateur familial
ou un ordinateur public, dans ce cas,
la navigation privée vous garantit
de ne pas rester connecté
à votre boîte mail, par mégarde,
ou de dévoiler toutes vos recherches
dans l'historique du navigateur.
En résumé,
ce que fait la navigation privée,
nous pouvons le reproduire à l'identique
en navigation classique, simplement,
en effaçant l'historique, les cookies et les données de formulaires enregistrées.
En revanche, si vous cherchez
à vous cacher de votre fournisseur d'accès
à Internet, du réseau de votre employeur,
des grosses entreprises du numérique
et de la publicité ciblée ou même des espions et services de renseignement,
la navigation privée n'offre absolument
aucune protection supplémentaire
par rapport à la navigation classique.
Vos données de navigation
sont toujours accessibles par des tiers.
C'est d'ailleurs très utile pour la police
qui peut saisir votre ordinateur
dans le cadre d'une enquête.
Vous pensez avoir effacé votre historique,
mais en réalité,
il ne l'est pas de façon sécurisée.
En utilisant des techniques particulières,
les enquêteurs sont capables de remonter jusqu'à vos données effacées.
On appelle ça "l'analyse forensique".
Vous l'avez compris, la navigation privée
est à dissocier de la navigation anonyme.
Seulement, avec la petite image
d'espion à lunettes et leur terminologie
de navigation incognito,
les navigateurs web sont les premiers
à entretenir ce flou.
Google, avec son navigateur Chrome, est d'ailleurs en procès
pour tromperie à ce sujet.
Il y a, quand même, une chose qui me turlupine.
Existe t-il vraiment un moyen de rester anonyme sur internet ?
Oui, l'idée serait d'utiliser un intermédiaire, un tiers de confiance.
Au lieu de se connecter à un site web
en notre nom avec notre adresse IP,
on le ferait via
un ou plusieurs ordinateurs intermédiaires, pour brouiller les pistes.
Cet intermédiaire, on appelle ça : "un proxy".
Pour mettre en place cette technique,
beaucoup vont recommander un VPN,
un Réseau Privé Virtuel qui,
pour simplifier, consiste à rerouter
l'ensemble de votre trafic
via un ordinateur intermédiaire,
potentiellement à l'autre bout de la planète.
Ça fonctionne, mais ça revient à déplacer le problème
de notre opérateur internet à notre VPN.
Et je ne suis pas bien sûr,
d'avoir envie de faire confiance
à une société au Panama.
En revanche, il existe un réseau
un peu particulier, le réseau Tor,
pour The Onion Router.
C'est un réseau mondial et décentralisé,
superposé au réseau classique,
qu'on connaît tous.
Associé à son navigateur,
il transmet chaque requête à au moins
3 serveurs, 3 proxy choisis au hasard,
à l'image des couches d'un oignon.
Et, c'est pour le coup
plutôt efficace et sécurisé.
Enfin, la façon la plus efficace
de ne pas laisser de traces, c'est d'en
laisser le moins possible initialement
et de tout détruire en partant.
Pour ça, il existe des systèmes
à installer directement sur une clé USB.
On peut alors être protégé
quel que soit l'ordinateur qu'on utilise.
Edward Snowden lui même, le lanceur
d'alerte de la NSA,
recommande ce système.
Vous connectez la clé USB à un ordinateur,
que ce soit le vôtre
ou celui de quelqu'un d'autre
et dès lors, toutes les connexions
transitent par le réseau Tor.
Rien n'est stocké sur le disque
dur de l'ordinateur,
tout est indépendant.
Quand vous débranchez la clé USB,
tout est effacé.
C'est comme
si vous n'étiez jamais passé par là.
C'est bien beau Michael,
mais tout le monde n'est pas Edward
Snowden, ni journaliste d'investigation.
Le mieux, c'est donc de commencer par
refuser les cookies tiers et les trackers.
Ce sera déjà un très bon début.
Et comme la tâche est pour le moins ardue et, bien, des extensions
pour votre navigateur permettent
de faire ce travail à votre place, refuser
automatiquement les cookies tiers
et empêcher les trackers d'agir.
Certes, vous ne serez pas anonyme,
mais vous serez moins suivi.
Allez, merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout.
C'est le meilleur soutien que vous pouvez
nous apporter.
Et, si ce type de sujet vous plait,
n'hésitez pas à nous en proposer d'autres.
On regardera ça de très près avec Michael.
Allez à très bientôt,
chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux.